hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today
so today let's solve binary tree right
side
view the problem is pretty
self-explanatory we're given a binary
tree
and basically imagine you're standing on
the right side of it so this is the tree
imagine we have a person standing over
here right you can see
from the right side you can see
everything on the right side
and so what nodes can this person see
well they can see
the root node right there's nothing
blocking that they can see
this node can they see two well you
can't really see two because it's behind
this node right it's basically blocking
it's blocking this node right
and the same thing with these two nodes
right we can see four because it's the
right most right like
imagine the person sees this but you
can't really see that
because it's being blocked by the four
so
that so when you just look at this
example this problem seems really easy
right so your first thought might just
be okay start at the root
and keep going to the right
right just keep going down and we'll get
the right side view right every node on
the right side
but we can make a counter example pretty
easily to show that that actually won't
always work imagine this node 5
had a left child right like let's let's
say it has 7
over here now now you can see that our
result is going to be
one three four we can't include these
nodes because they're being blocked
but there's nothing over here right the
seven is not being blocked so if this
was our input tree then
our output would be one three four and
we'd have to add a seven to that because
look at our person
they can technically see down here so
basically what this means is we can't
only look at the right children right
so you can actually solve this problem
with a breadth first search i know most
tree problems you can just do depth
first search but this problem can
actually be solved with breadth first
search there actually
is a depth first search solution but i'm
going to explain the breadth first
search solution
to you because in some ways it's easier
and you might know brett's first search
in a tree is also known as level
order traversal so it's also known as
level order traversal which
you're gonna see why it's called that
just about now
so instead of saying that there's a
person over here that can see
only the right side of the tree another
way of framing this problem is saying
okay for each
level right each level of the tree we
want the
right most node so the first level it's
pretty easy because there's only one
node
so we'll just take the one from that
what about this
level right we look at the nodes
together for this level we want the
right most so we get the three
next we want the third level
and what's the right most value it's
gonna be the four right
and lastly we take the last
level and there's only one node it's
seven
so we're going to get d7 so with a
picture this is pretty
obvious right it's really easy to know
what we're doing with a picture but
actually
writing the code for level order
traversal is a little bit tricky
and i'm gonna show you how to do that
basically how we're gonna implement this
is with a q data structure so initially
what we're gonna do
is add the root node to our queue so
we're gonna add
one to our queue and we're also going to
have a result
array so now what we're going to do is
take a look
at our rightmost value in the queue it's
so we're going to add 1 to our result
next now we're no longer looking at this
node we are looking at
its children basically the next level so
we can get that by taking the left and
right child
and adding them to our q and removing
the leftmost value from our q so we add
the two
and the three to the q and it's
important that we do it
in order right the left and right the
left has to be added
first and then the right because we
always want to get the right most value
when we you know add to our result so
now
this is the second level of our
uh tree right so what are we going to do
again we're just going to take the
rightmost value in this case it's 3
add it to our result and next what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
the
leftmost value pop it right but before
we pop it we want to take its children
notice it doesn't have a left child
right that's null and the right child is
5. so we're going to take its children
and add them to the queue so now we're
adding
5 to the q so we're done with 2. next we
have to remove
3 from our cube because we're done with
this level we want to look at the next
level
so we remove three but before we remove
three we have to add its left and right
child
notice it doesn't have a left child but
it has a right child four so we're going
to add four to our q
so now look at our cube we have two
elements and these two elements
represent the third level so what we're
going to do
now is take the rightmost value once
again
in our queue and add it to our result
because that's
the rightmost value in this level
of the tree and now we're going to
repeat that process so for five we're
done looking at five but we have to look
at its left and right child it has one
child
seven so we remove five and we add
seven to our q and we also look at four
so
we're done looking at 4 right so we pop
it but before we pop it we want to look
at its children notice
both of the children are null so
basically we've reached our base case
we don't end up adding more elements to
the q
in this case and now there's only a
single
element remaining in our queue and that
element represents the fourth
level of our tree and the rightmost node
in that level is seven so we can add
seven to our result
and we know we still have to remove
seven now right so remove seven from our
q
notice it didn't have any children right
both of the children were
null so we've reached our base case we
cannot add
any more elements to the queue therefore
the queue is now
empty so now we can stop running our
algorithm we know that our result
is complete we have no more nodes left
to traverse
so now let's translate this into code so
i'm going to initialize a
empty result i'm also going to have a
q so in python we can do that like this
it's called a dec and i'm going to
initialize it just like i did in the
picture with a single element
and that's going to be root now it's
possible that root
could be null so technically it's
possible that our q
could have null values and i'm going to
show you how i'm going to handle that
so while the queue is non-empty that
means we can
pop elements from the queue so i'm going
to get
the right side element from this current
level i'm initially going to set it to
null
and i'm going to get the current queue
length
right the current length of the queue so
right now imagine
it's just a single level right our q at
any given point contains
one level at a time so for this level
i'm gonna get the length
and then what i'm gonna do is go through
every element
in this level so for only q length right
the initial
length because we know this q is going
to continuously be
updated so i'm going to go through every
element
and i'm going to pop it so q pop
left right we know we're popping
elements from the left and we're adding
elements to the right
now we know the node actually could be
null so what i'm going to check is
if node is not null if it is null then
we can just go to the next
iteration of the loop so if it's not
null what i'm going to do is update our
right side
to that node so you can see that after
this entire
loop is done executing what right side
is going to have
is the last node that was in
this current level of the queue and
since this node is not
null i'm just going to take its children
so
so node.left and i'm going to append
that to our queue
and also i'm going to take node.right
and append it to the queue
now it's technically possible that these
children could be null
but we know that if they are in the next
iteration of the while loop
we'll come back here and we'll verify
that the nodes are non-null
before we you know update our right side
and it's also important that you add the
left node
before you add the right node and after
this
after this for loop is done executing
what we have done is taken every node in
the current level
popped it right that's what the pop is
doing and taking
all the children of that level and added
them to the queue so basically what
we've done is removed
the elements from the previous level and
added the elements from the next
level so that's good and the other thing
that we did is we took the right side
the right
most node in that level and had it
stored
in the right side variable so now we can
take
to our result we can take that right
side variable and append it to the
result
but not just uh right side we actually
want right side dot
value because we're trying to append the
values and it's actually technically
possible
initially right side was null in one of
the base cases
you know the right side could actually
be null
once we've reached the last level so
we're going to verify that
right side is non-null so once we've
done that
and once this cue is empty meaning we've
gone through every single
level of the tree then all we have to do
is return our result
so there it is it's a pretty efficient
solution even though this percentage
doesn't indicate that
so i hope this was helpful if you
enjoyed like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon